it all must make sense there has to be a
reason things don't just happen
when the finale of season two ends
you're left with this girl who has kind
of bested this scary mythic figure
vanity is a sin
aunt josephine
and she's sitting there on the bed and
says you know i know what's gonna happen
i know they're coming for us
we pick up three months later and leanne
is in the middle of absolute paranoia i
told you that we can't trust strangers
she's anticipating an attack that hasn't
happened yet
you ready for food buddy num num time on
the surface you really get a sense that
the family is doing well i thought you'd
want to see this
[Music]
i think the family has been lulled into
thinking we made it i think that
everything's happening the way that it's
supposed to
don't worry
and dorothy's very grateful
that she has her child back she's very
sympathetic
to leanne as a teenage member of a cult
[Music]
but can you leave the church can you
leave this cult i just want to
understand what you believe
that's all when leanne starts exhibiting
darker tendencies and destructive
choices believe me i am frightened about
what she might do next dorothy is a
realization
that she's dealing with someone really
really unstable
each character in the family has their
own point of view about what's happening
sean believes that this is a miracle and
leanne is the instrument of that i still
can't believe we're here
on the other side of it
julian is a person that struggles with
addiction in many forms and in this
season his addiction is leanne
leanne continually starts to surprise
herself then her
realization of how powerful she is grows
to a
scary and very dark place god won't fix
you
there's a defiant part of her that's
going to emerge and it will get kind of
scary when she's pushed too far
i'm doing this for you fans of servant
will find
that
we found our stride
the story kind of keeps unfolding and
you're going to learn more and more
about the the mystery the things you've
been waiting to hear about and there's
so many shocks and surprises there's
life and death every single episode
season three should leave your jaw
hanging open
you